by the way folks sometimes people cringe
or they struggle with me mentioning that
we have built wealth we started from
nothing and I was a millionaire by the
time I was 26 and I lost everything
because I was stupid so I know what
stupid looks like I know what broke
looks like I've been all of that and I
was not born with a you know any kind of
a silver spoon at all other than my
parents believed in honesty and hard
work if you call that a silver spoon
that's an advantage because some people
weren't born and families that believed
in that stuff but hard work and honesty
is you know kind of a commodity these
days so I have that advantage and I've
had the advantage of being able to help
millions and millions and millions and
millions of millions of people with
their money in their life and a lot of
those millions of people have bought
books and done other things to learn and
they've made made their lives better
because they've learned and in the
process we made money and we do the
stuff that we teach Shanna and I live
exactly like we teach she has an
envelope system in her purse to this day
and everything we own is paid for and
always has been since we went broke
we're not gonna and I'm gonna be
involved period in the idea of debt we
invest exactly like I tell you to invest
I don't have some secret super secret
rich guy thing on the side i buy real
estate that i pay cash for including the
building i'm sitting in like i just
mentioned and i buy good growth stock
mutual funds i don't own a single single
stock I don't own a whole life policy
and I don't lease a car and I don't have
a credit card I've got to debit cards
that's it
I actually do the stuff we teach so
there's nothing hypocritical here and as
a matter of fact when I say we've built
wealth and we have a net worth of over a
hundred million dollars most of that's
in real estate and and this company
obviously and so am i bragging no I'm
bragging on the stuff we teach the stuff
we teach works you shouldn't listen to
someone who's
for financial advice if a guy lives in
his mother's basement and has a
financial blog nobody cares what he
thinks about money he lives in his
mother's basement or you shouldn't care
you shouldn't let people who aren't
winning in a space tell you how to live
in that space you've been married 16
times I hope this one works for you but
I'm not reading your book on marriage
your kids are little hellions running
around all over the place and their
lives are falling apart and they're
destructive to themselves and others I'm
not reading your book on parenting or
the leadership for that matter you can't
even lead in your own home you know it
there you go
I mean that's it and so the entre
leadership book is how we've grown this
business from a card table in my living
room to 719 people working on our team
right now and we went best place to work
10 years we've won best place to work in
Nashville why because we're the best
place to work that's why so yeah I got
something to teach you about leadership
it's what we've done here now you grow a
business how you run a business I've got
the whole entre leadership movement and
being San Antonio this coming weekend
for our sold-out entree Leadership
Summit with Condoleezza Rice and a bunch
of other wonderful teachers and leaders
and guess who I have on the pack guess
we have speaking people have actually
been leaders Condoleezza Rice is
actually a leader Dan Cathy is actually
the leader of chick-fil-a Kelly is
actually the leader at Southwest air
you'll be speaking the president of
Southwest air is gonna be there Allen
actually was the leader at Ford Malloy
Holloway I can never pronounce his name
sorry Allen you have to teach me how to
say it this weekend for sure in person
but he led Ford Ford Motor Company you
can learn something in leadership from a
guy who led Ford Motor Company but not
someone who's never made a payroll not
someone who's never led a team you don't
want learning leadership from somebody's
got a theory they read about it and they
had an epiphany in the middle of the
night give me a break you know actual
practitioners who people who win in a
space if you are hire a personal trainer
you don't want to be 400 pounds
unless you're learning how to be a sumo
wrestler I mean you know I guess you
would want it then and how to properly
suit up with your diaper in the whole
bit
you know I mean you got to know how to
do this stuff in the area you're gonna
win in find somebody's winning in that
area so you don't want pro people giving
you financial advice I do the stuff we
teach for the last 30 years and oh by
the way it works this is the Dave Ramsey
show